let's say I have some transformation
from r2 to r2 and it's essentially just
a multiplication times a matrix and we
know that all linear transformations can
be expressed as a multiplication of a
matrix but this one is equal to the
matrix the matrix one three to six times
whatever vector you give me in my domain
times x1 x2 now let's say I have some
subset in my co domain so let me draw
this right here so my domain looks like
that it's r2 and of course my function
or my transformation Maps elements of r2
into elements of its codomain which also
happens to be our two I could show it
mapping into itself but for the sake of
simplicity let's draw my co domain here
and our transformation of course maps
for any Mel event here the
transformation of that will be an
association or mapping into r2 now what
if we take some subset of r2 so let's
say some subset of r2 and let's just say
it's a set of two vectors the zero
vector n r2 and the vector 1 2 so it's
literally let's say it's this point let
me do in a different color let's say
this is my zero vector and r2 I'm not
plotting I'm just showing that there in
this very set there in our - that's my
zero vector and let's say the vector 1 2
is here 1 2 what I want to know is what
are all of the vectors in my domain
whose transformations map to this subset
map to this point so I want to know I'm
essentially wanted I want to know the
preimage of s so the preimage of s let
me be careful the preimage of s under
this is the pre-image of s under t and i
said be careful because when you just
say preimage of something without saying
under something else you implies that
you're taking well when you say image of
something it implies you're taking the
MA
of an entire transformation like I
showed you I think two videos ago but
when you're taking the image or pre
image of a set yet make sure you say
under what transformation so we want to
know the pre image of this subset of our
codomain under the transformation T we
write this as T to the or T inverse of s
and we saw it in the last video this is
all of the X all of the elements in our
in our domain in our domain where the
transformation of those X's is a member
of the subset of our codomain that we're
trying to find the pre image of right
now what is another way of writing this
well this is you could write this is
we're trying to look for all of the X's
in our domain such that this vector
let's call this a that matrix a such
that a times X is a member of s so that
means a times X has to be equal to this
or has to be equal to that so that means
a times our vector X has to be equal to
the zero vector or a times our vector X
has to be equal to this vector one two
this is the exact this is the the exact
same statement as this one right here I
just made it a little bit more explicit
in terms of our actual transformation a
times X and in terms of what our actual
set is our set is just two vectors so if
we wanted to determine the preimage if
we want to determine the pre image of s
so we write that T in the pre image of s
under T that's set there we essentially
have to just find all of the X's that
satisfy these two equations right there
so this equation that's so we have to
find all of the X's that satisfy the
first one right here is the matrix one
three to six times x1 x2 is equal to the
zero vector that's this equation right
there we need to find all of the
solutions to that and you might already
recognize that all of the solutions to
this the all of the X's that satisfy
this is the null space of the
matrix I just thought I'd point that out
on the side now that's not the only one
we also have to solve this guy over here
I'll do that in blue so the solute the
the preimage of s under t is going to be
all the solutions to this or plus all of
the solutions to 1 3 to 6 times x1 x2 is
equal to 1/2 now we could just solve
this with an Augmented matrix so my
Augmented matrix would look like 1 3 2 6
0 0 and here my Augmented matrix would
be 1 3 2 6 1 2 let's put this in reduced
row echelon form so let's replace our
second row with our second row minus 2
times the first row so what do we get
our first row stays the same 1 3 0 let
me do it let me do them simultaneously
let me solve these systems in parallel
so my first system stays first row stays
the same 1 3 1 and in both cases because
I just want to get the left-hand side of
my Augmented matrix into reduced row
echelon form I can apply the same row
operation so I'm replacing my second row
with 2 times my first row so 2 minus 2
times 1 is 0 6 minus 2 times 3 is 0 and
of course 0 minus 2 times 0 is 0 here 2
2 minus 2 times 1 is 0 6 minus 2 times 3
is 0 and 2 minus 2 times 1 is 0 so we
get all these zeros and we're actually
done we have both of these augmented
matrices in reduced row echelon form and
how do we go back to solve all of the
X's x1 and x2 that satisfy these well
you recognize that our first columns
right here our pivot columns and these
are associated with our variable X 1 so
we know that X 1 is a pivot variable and
we know that the second column is a non
pivot column because it has no ones in
it and so it's associated and it's
associated with X 2 and since X 2 isn't
a pivot column we know that X 2 is a
free variable X 2
is a free variable which essentially set
means we can set x2 to be anything so
let's just set x2 x2 is equal to t where
t is a member of the reals in this case
what is x1 going to be equal to so here
this top equation says let me write it
if we just kind of go back to this world
right here this means that x1 plus 3x2
is equal to this 0 here this top line
right here says x1 plus 3x2 is equal to
1 and so if we say x2 is equal to T this
equation becomes x1 plus 3 T is equal to
0 subtract T from 3t from both sides you
get X 1 is equal to minus 3t and then
this equation you get X 1 is equal to if
we substitute x2 with T is X 1 is equal
to 1 minus 1 minus 3t now if we wanted
to write the solution sets and kind of
vector notations the solution set for
this for this guy right here for this
first for this first equation right
there it's going to be x1 x2 is equal to
what it's going to be equal to you have
your it's going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to well x2 is
just going to be equal to T times it's
just going to be equal to T so let me
just write it there so it's going to be
equal to T times x2 is just T times 1 is
just equal to T I made that definition
up here and then what's x1 equal to it's
equal to minus 3 times T so if I put a T
out here as a scalar it's just minus 3
times T so this is a solution for this
first equation some where where T is a
member of the reals or T so it's just
scalar multiples of the vector minus 3/1
and if we think of this as a position
vector this will be a line in r2 and
I'll draw that in a second so that's the
solution for this first equation and
then the solution for the second
equation the solution for the sec
equation how can we set this up it's
going to be let me make sure you can see
it it is x1 x2 and let's see X x2 once
again is just T times 1 so let me just
write it right let me just write it like
this
so it's T times 1 that's X 2 now what's
X 1 X 1 is equal to 1 minus 3 times T so
if we do a minus 3 that gives us our
minus 3 times T but we need not do a 1
minus that or 1 plus -3 times T so what
we can do is we could say that all the
solution set here is equal to the vector
1 here so now we have 1 plus minus 3
times T 4 X 1 and then here we can say
is 0 X 2 is equal to 0 plus T or X 2 is
equal to T so this is the solution set
for the second for the second equation
so our pre image of s and remember s s
was just these two points in our
codomain the pre image of s under t is
essentially all of the X's that satisfy
these two equations and let's actually
graph those let me turn on my graphs it
makes it look a little bit messy but let
me graph it well let me graph it down
here let me copy and paste my my two
results so I get then I want to paste it
so those are my two results let me put
my pen back on and now what I can do is
I can graph it right here so let's see
the it's a solution set for that first
equation is all the multiples of the
vector minus 3 1 so the vector minus 3
1-3 1 looks like this this this solution
minus 3 1 looks like this looks like
that that's the vector minus 3 1 but my
solution set is all the scalar multiples
of minus 3 1 this is a comma right here
right so if I just take all the scalar
multiples of minus 3 1 it's going to
look like this so if you take 2 times it
you're going to have
- six - so you're going to get like that
so it's going to be all of let's see
it's going to be all of these points
right here I wish I could draw a little
bit neater but I think you get the idea
it's going to be a line like that that
is that solution set right there and
then what is this solution set right
here it's the vector 1 0 so we go out 1
0 so that's there plus scalar multiples
of - 3 1 so plus scalar multiples of
this so Plus scalar multiples so if we
just had one scalar multiple of minus 3
one will end up will end up right right
there but we want to put all the scalar
multiples of it because we have this tee
right here so we're going to end up with
another line with the same slope
essentially let's just shift it a little
bit it shifted one to the right it
shifted one to the right now what why
did we do all of this remember what we
wanted to find out is what were all of
the vectors
what were all of the vectors let me turn
off the graph paper what were all of the
vectors in our domain that when we apply
the transformation map two vectors map
two vectors within our subset of our
codomain map to either 0 0 or the vector
1 2 and we figured that all of those
vectors out by solving these two
equations and we're able to see that
these two lines and when I turn my graph
paper on they map to the points so when
these guys when you apply the
transformation I'll draw it all on the
same graph they map when you apply the
transformation to the points 0 0 and to
the point 1 2 which was right here so
all of these points when you apply the
transformation and actually all of the
ones in the blue they map to 0 0 because
we they solved this top equation all the
ones in orange when you apply the
transformation map to the point 1 2 map
to the point 1 2 now this blue line
right here this has a special a special
name for it and I actually touched on it
a little bit before right everything in
this blue line
right if I call this set right here and
let's call it B for blue this is the
blue line that's this set of vectors
right here everything there when I apply
my transformation of that of those blue
vectors or if I take the image of my
blue vector of my blue set under T it
all Maps it all maps to the zero vector
it all maps to the zero vector it equals
the set of the zero vector right then we
saw that right there and I remember well
earlier in the video I pointed out that
look this this set right here this is
equivalent to the null space right the
null space the null space of a matrix
the null space of a matrix is all the
vectors that if you multiply it by that
matrix you get zero so this is the
similar idea here is this transformation
is defined by a matrix and we're saying
what are all of the X's that when you
transform eight when you transform them
when you transform them you get the zero
vector and so this idea this blue thing
right here is called the kernel the
kernel of T and sometimes it's written
as just shorthand keer of T and this
literally is all of the vectors that if
you apply the transformation let me
write it this way it's all of the
vectors in our domain which was R 2 such
that the transformation of those vectors
is equal to the zero vector this is the
definition of the kernel and if the
transformation if our transformation is
equal to is equal to some matrix times
some vector we know that any linear
transformation can be written as a
matrix vector product then the kernel
the kernel of T is the same thing as the
null space of a and we saw that earlier
in the video anyway hopefully you found
that reasonably useful